republican congressman marjorie taylor
greene is on trial
sort of
green has not committed any crime but
georgia democrats have dragged her into
court anyway by using an arcane
provision of the law to try to stop her
from running for re-election
georgia democrats are arguing that the
14th amendment bars greene from seeking
re-election because one of the lesser
noted provisions of that amendment
borrows people who have quote engaged in
insurrection or rebellion against the
united states from serving in congress
never mind that marjorie taylor green
has never been convicted of insurrection
never mind that she's never been charged
with insurrection never mind that she
never engaged in an insurrection these
democrats are arguing that because
marjorie greene raised questions about
the 2020 election
you know the election where they changed
all the rules right beforehand that you
know that one uh because marjorie taylor
greene uh raised any of these questions
because the horn hat guy took pictures
in the capitol on january 6 that that
somehow disqualifies this popular
congressman from holding office you
probably have not heard of this
provision of the 14th amendment of the
u.s constitution because it has not
seriously been used in about 150 years
hasn't been used really since
reconstruction in the years after the
civil war the union worked to prevent
former confederate officials from
holding office and then since then
the provision has hardly ever even been
mentioned
until now
just this year democrats in north
carolina tried to pull the same stunt to
keep another popular republican
congressman madison cawthorne off the
ballot there
indiana democrats tried to keep
republican jim banks off the ballot
the courts fortunately in north carolina
and indiana were both responsible enough
to laugh this scheme out of court
george on the other hand is letting the
circus proceed
and you know that
the term 1776
is actually a term that's sometimes used
in politics today
i don't know if you've noticed our state
seal here in georgia i know you're not
from georgia but as you can see we we
enjoy our history and we're proud of our
freedoms 1776 is on our state seal right
and it's also a term that's used in
political discourse in america today i
don't use it as a term of violence
but you use it as a term right
so the the democrats if you couldn't
catch what he was doing there the
democrats are insinuating that if you
endorse the number 1776
that you're an insurrectionist
that if you endorse the year of the
american revolution you are somehow an
opponent of america you're anti-american
if you support the american revolution
so imply the democrats it doesn't just
stop there that wasn't marjorie taylor
green's crime was not merely using the
phrase 1776
which as she points out appears on the
state seal no no it goes further she
her her strategy around independence day
was even more insidious
the last thing you say in the video is
we aren't the people that are going to
go quietly into the night you recall
that part yes
now that phrase we aren't the people
that are going to go quietly into the
night
that's not something that you came up
with on your own is it
i have no idea what you mean well that's
something that you borrowed from a movie
script right
i don't know what you're talking about
you borrow that line from the movie
independence day right
this is what they're getting around
they're dragging a member of congress
before a judge to
suggest that some of her lines the the
sort of now even cliche very popular
lines she's using are from a movie like
independence day by the way the line
goes back much further than independence
day ridiculous as it sounds
this stunt may actually work and no
one's talking about it and it is a major
threat to our electoral integrity
this this could theoretically make it
all the way up to the supreme court if a
lower court does not strike this stunt
down first
it doesn't look particularly good for
democrats who know that they can't beat
margaery green in an election so now
they're just trying to pervert the law
to prevent voters from having the chance
to elect her in the first place but it's
not just about green
and it's not about madison cawthorne and
it's not about jim banks and actually in
my humble opinion it's not about 2022 at
all
this is
so clearly a test run by democrats to
see if they can keep donald trump off
the ballot in 2024 for the same reason
it's an admission that democrats don't
think they can beat him fair and square
it's an admission that they're willing
to bend the law and pervert the
electoral process to maintain power and
dare i say it i don't want to get in
trouble dare i say it
it's an admission that maybe the people
such as green who doubted certain
aspects of the 2020 election
had every right to be skeptical i'm
michael knowles this is the michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from epic ape
who says what's disappointing about that
judge striking down the mask mandate is
mr knowles won't have to do his fouchy
impression as much anymore
do not worry you
do not worry dr fauci is not going
anywhere okay unless you banish him to
saint helena dr fauci is gonna be here
for a long long time okay don't don't i
wouldn't worry about that well i would
worry about that actually but the silver
lining is i will uh do my dr fauci
impression now when when you want to
turn away from the horrors bedeviling
our politics you want to focus on
something good good for you good for
your family good for your country
you got to go check out good ranchers
what do you think i had for dinner on
saturday i think you know saturday in
the knolls household means good ranchers
i had delicious new york strip steaks
that was for me and sweet little alisa
cute baby june had his better than
organic chicken with the delicious good
ranchers garlic rub on top which is just
enough to really spice up the flavor but
not too much it's not overwhelming you
can still put your own spin on it it's
just magnificent i love these guys the
beef is extraordinarily high quality it
the the craziest part of it all is that
right now we're in this historic moment
where food prices are going through the
roof and good ranchers is giving you the
opportunity not only to get actual good
american beef but to lock in your price
so you can lock in your price right now
even though the prices are getting
higher as summer approaches you can lock
it in and get a 30 discount on prime
stakes and better than organic chicken
today goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality that
you've been looking for go to good
ranchers right now take the guesswork
out of the grocery store shop local have
it shipped to your door use codenals
canadawles and enjoy your box of 100
american meat and your 30 savings order
now to combat inflation with good
ranchers american meat delivered
the marjory green
hearing
this
attempt
to use the 14th amendment to stop this
popular woman from seeking re-election
it tells you everything you need to know
about 2022 and 2024 and the modern
democrat party they don't think they can
win at the ballot box
they don't think in a fair and square
election that they can win and so
they've got to prevent her from even
getting to the place where
she can be put up for a vote where
people can vote for her and send her
back to congress and they got to do the
same thing to jim banks and they got to
do the same thing to madison cawthorne
and they have to do the same thing to
donald trump because despite democrats
insisting that joe biden got 70
bazillion votes the most votes of any
human being ever in the history of the
world they don't really believe it they
don't really think he's popular they
don't think they can win fair and square
they're going to try to change all the
voting rules and turn election day into
election month and there or more they're
going to try to turn
the
ballot box into widespread mail-in
ballots even when it's in direct
violation of state constitutions such as
in pennsylvania they're going to try to
turn the election counting process which
should take about a day or two into a
really it should be even quicker than
that they're going to try to turn it
into a weeks-long process they're just
going to try to cheat and steal the
election that's what they're going to
try to do you're seeing it right now if
they were confident that marjorie green
is a crazy kooky insurrectionist who
says all sorts of insane things
and that nobody would support her then
they wouldn't be taking her to court
right now they would just let her run
for re-election and they would beat her
but they're not going to beat her
because they don't they aren't confident
of that and they've got nothing to offer
the country
when when the i said this last week when
i was speaking
at boston when the right attacks the
left
we just put their own words before them
when the left attacks the right they
censor us they intimidate us they try to
kick us out of the public square they
try to arrest us
they do whatever they can to shut us up
when we attack the left we present their
own words before them that is what the
libs of tick-tock saga is about
an anonymous a formerly anonymous
twitter account called lives of tick
tock just reposted already public videos
of libs from a platform that a lot of
younger people are on to a platform that
older people are on which is twitter and
it was there was no editing
there was no deceptive technique
libs of tick tock just presented what
the left was saying and the left got so
upset about it that they got the
washington post to dox the woman behind
the account and try to shut down the
account and try to silence them because
they know that what the libs are
suggesting which is the sexualization of
children the promotion of critical race
theory the the erasure of america's
borders the list goes on and on and on
what the left is selling the american
people are not buying and so the libs
have to shut us up that's what this
twitter saga is about right now with
elon musk potentially buying twitter
twitter has taken very aggressive
targeted steps to silence conservatives
most infamously
they kicked
the duly elected sitting president of
the united states off of twitter and
facebook and google while he was
president
they they did that because they felt
that he was too persuasive he had too
much influence but they do it to a ton
of other conservatives they did it to
the babylon b for goodness sakes and so
elon musk has been going in and and
the twitter board
along with major financial institutions
blackrock state street the kingdom of
saudi arabia for some reason came in and
they said oh no we can't have free
speech on twitter oh no we can't have
conservatives have more of a voice in
the public square than they currently do
and so they they teamed up and they
actually harmed shareholder value to try
to stop elon musk from taking over and
freeing up the speech of conservatives
but it appears that that is not working
there is breaking news right now it's
happening right now as we are recording
that
twitter is finally relenting because
elon musk raised enough money to
potentially just buy out the company and
he's threatening a tender offer and he's
doing all sorts of of maneuvers that
looks like he's going to be able to
outfox the twitter board there's a
report out now that that musk and
twitter were up all night
negotiating what the buyout looks like
this is happening in real time so we'll
update you during this show if anything
changes but but they're fighting it
tooth and nail because
they know that
the the value of controlling our
political order is a hell of a lot
higher than 54.20 per share which is
what elon musk is offering for twitter
that's much higher than the actual value
of the twitter company but the value of
that political power to keep half the
country
basically gagged up and silenced that is
extraordinarily extraordinarily
valuable
now when you're thinking about your
valuables i strongly recommend you get a
will which is why you need epic will
right now go to epicwill.com use promo
code knowles if you're listening to this
show something tells me you're pretty
tuned in with politics you care about
what happens to your country you care
about what kind of country you're going
to leave to your kids and to your your
kids kids
well on a really basic level
have you decided what's going to happen
with your personal legacy
what's going to happen with your with
literally your kids if something should
happen to you you've got to get that in
order first before you worry about those
big political questions it's why you
need to set your will if you have not
made a will yet you are not alone but
we're going to make it super easy for
you at epic epicwill.com when you use
promo code knowles we are extremely
excited that epic wheel is partnering
with us at the daily wire they're
protecting our staff and our families
let them protect yours epicwheel.com use
promo code knolls that's how easy it is
you just secure your future in as little
as five minutes you get a complete
package starting at 119 that's an
incredibly good deal
when you use promo code knowles you will
save 10 epicwheel.com this will be the
most important five minutes you spend
today
libs of tick tock
has just gotten a death threat
uh libs of tick tock look a lot of
people on the internet get death threats
some of them are more credible than
others this one seems credible to me
it was from this anonymous account that
says assassination mode activated
activation word libs of tick-tock target
then
they mention this woman's name some
personal information begin operation and
it's a picture of a guy holding what is
either a fully automatic weapon or at
least a pretty serious looking black
rifle
why would this be a serious
assassination threat because the
washington post doxed the woman and even
hyperlinked to her physical address
so
now libs of tick tock look she's
standing firm the girl who's behind that
account is standing firm she's
continuing to post content but i get why
she would be scared right now the post
put out
as much of her personal information as
they possibly could
and and there are crazy people in this
world and and they're doing it because
they know that they can't refute what
she's saying they can't argue with her
why would how could they argue with her
she's just posting their own words and
so what they've got to try to do is
threaten her and intimidate her and
silence her
and possibly kill her and possibly
actually kill her
there is no journalistic reason to have
docked libs of tick tock
there is there is no noble journalistic
cause that was served by that the only
reason to do it is to impel people to
harass her or attack her or possibly
kill her that's the only that's the only
possible explanation you tell me what
else could the washington post have been
after
why else would they hyperlink to her
physical address if
if any of the libs can come up with a
different explanation a less nefarious
explanation i'm open to hear it i just
can't think of one and i don't think
anyone else can either
the dems
are furious now okay i'm not saying that
the republicans are not playing politics
in a tough way
i'm not saying that it's the poor
beleaguered republicans who are just
getting rolled over by the democrats
that's not true actually the republicans
are getting much more aggressive in a
way that i think is terrific
but the difference is the republicans
are doing it within the political
process and the democrats are doing it
by
outside of the political process by
trying to dox people by trying to
prevent people from running for office
in the first place
great example of this is florida florida
just decided to take away certain
special government privileges from the
disney corporation because disney is
wielding its immense political power to
try to trans the kids and undermine the
will of florida voters so
the the republicans have gone in there
in the state legislature and governor
desantis and taken away certain special
tax privileges and the florida dems are
losing their mind over it
and we will vote on these two bills
it is my hope that we will be able to
proceed civilly
and with decorum and with respect for
one another read the next bill
by sunder bradley senate bill 4c built
to be entitled an act leading to
independent special district
members we will either go into
structured debate or we will call the
previous question
representative runner you're recognized
for a motion
mr speaker i move the previous question
on the bill
representative renner moves the previous
question on the bill this motion is not
debatable and requires a majority vote
all in favor say aye
all opposed no
show the bill show emotion passes we
will now proceed to call the previous
question
i think it was you know remember that
girl from election night 2016 the one in
the kind of neon jacket who when when
trump was announced as the winner she
goes no and she screams to the sky i
think she must now be an elected member
of the florida legislature
on the democrat side because that's what
you're no no you can't take away special
privileges from a 200 billion
corporation
no
i i'm old enough to remember occupy wall
street you remember that that was the
big leftist cause du jour in 2012 2013
when the the libs were protesting the
big corporations
and the terrible stinking corruption now
the big corporations were in bed with
big government remember that and now
they are demanding that the government
give special privileges to some of the
biggest corporations i love what
happened in florida
i think it's absolutely terrific i'm
glad that
the state legislature took away the
special privileges from disney
it is it is a slightly complicated issue
in that it's not going to take effect
for a year the there's a fair chance
that if if the special self-governing
district
uh that has conferred these tax
advantages to disney if that goes away
then the the debt that was incurred by
that self-governing district will
actually fall to the taxpayers of
florida so that's possible that's one
reason that maybe it's actually not
going to work out in the end uh there is
a debate also raging on the right and
and
among people from pretty different
political backgrounds
uh people well jeremy bourne god king of
the daily wire is in principle basically
opposed to what the florida legislature
did uh jenna ellis lawyer for president
trump also basically opposed to what the
florida legislature did i myself am for
it i think it's good but i recognize
it's a nuanced kind of situation uh ben
i think is basically for it but but the
fear is this
here's the fear that some people on the
right are raising that this is just
retaliation
by the florida legislature because this
corporation used its
massive political influence to say
something that
and to exercise its political speech in
a way that the government didn't like
yes and no yes and no one i think that's
how politics works generally i think
that big powerful interests whether it's
in government or whether it's in
technology or whether it's in
entertainment or whether it's in
corporate america or at large or whether
it's in the media wherever i think that
they exercise their power
and politics is a lot more than just the
government or just the agencies or just
the legislature that politics is really
how all of these interests interact
together politics is just how we get
along together in public life so i have
no problem if republicans and
conservatives have been completely
ousted from every major center of power
and the only thing that we can hold on
to these days is pretty much just the
legislature occasionally the governor's
mansion occasionally
then that's where we should exercise our
power i have no problem with that if if
you're more of the libertarian
persuasion maybe you have a little bit
more of a problem i certainly don't i'm
not a libertarian i'm a lowercase c
conservative so it doesn't really bother
me but i i do recognize that there can
be a fear here well what happens when
it's a conservative company let's say
it's i don't know domino's pizza are
they conservative i think some of the
pizza companies are at least right any
concern the daily wire let's say the
daily wire wants to exercise our
political speech what if we're punished
by the government i don't think that
quite holds up here because what the
government is doing is not issuing a new
penalty on disney it's not that the
government is going in and saying okay
we've got a special disney tax
we got the groomer tax and the groomer
tax is going to be paid exclusively by
disney no
what the democrat or what the florida
legislature is doing is saying
hey disney you had special privileges by
virtue of your being disney and we're
going to take those away now
and to me that's totally fair game
if a corporation wants to get in bed
with the government and wield its
immense political power to get special
privileges from the government and and
then wield its political power to try to
groom the kids and oppose what the
voters of florida want don't be
surprised when the privileges go away
regardless of where you stand on this
debate though it it should be clear as
day
the way republicans are fighting here
very aggressively is within
the political process
unlike the democrats who are doing it
outside of the political process who are
doing it by silencing politicians on
social media who are doing it by silent
by trying to kick politicians off the
ballot using bs provisions of the law
from 150 years ago
that the way they're doing it is outside
of that process because they think that
they're going to lose
but republicans are getting pretty tough
there's i love this story this out of
texas governor abbott
texas governor greg abbott
he's got this historic influx of illegal
aliens pouring over the border we had
two million illegal aliens come in last
year we're going to blow way past that
number this year and so what abbott is
doing is just sending buses of them to
washington dc i think this is great it's
a wonderful use of power you could have
some people who are really into the
nitty gritty of the procedure saying no
come on this isn't fair this is an
illegitimate use of government power i
don't think it is i think it's a it's
one of the few ways that the states can
still wield any power against the
federal government
states rights have been extraordinarily
weakened in america certainly since the
passage of the 17th amendment allowing
direct election of senators but really
for the whole history of the 20th
century and early 21st so if the best
thing a state can do is send buses of
illegals to dc that's fine i wish they
would send them to martha's vineyard i
wish they would send them to southampton
but we can take what we can get
now if you want a real
to exercise your power in how to knock
down the libs you should learn how to
debunk their arguments you can do it in
15 minutes or less
with
ben's show debunked
that's right ben has been busy working
on season two of debunked it is
extremely informative the first episode
debunks the common leftist talking point
that the rich don't pay their fair share
of taxes and it's available now only at
dailywire.com check out this sneak peek
you look at guys like elon musk and jeff
bezos and scrooge mcduck exactly when it
comes to taxes the rich do not pay their
fair share man
it's a familiar scene isn't it a liberal
friend co-worker cousin home from
college uses your dinner party to serve
up a word salad of leftist mantras don't
suffer through the bad political theater
join me every week and in 15 minutes or
less i will arm you with the facts to
counter the most common leftist claims
so you can stand up for what you believe
well what is a fair share by nearly
every measure the u.s has the most
progressive system of taxation in the
world i mean the top 40 percent of
earners pay 95 of all federal income tax
so they actually pay more than their
share of income so what part exactly do
you think is unfair
i think
they should just
pay more
bravo
become an expert debunked season two
only on the daily wire
okay as a mathematician and a physicist
i think i'm pretty qualified to say
this is that's actually the first time
i've seen that clip uh really really
great stuff even beyond learning the
political arguments i just want to see
more of the conversation i just want to
see more of the lib guy talking to his
host it's really that's captivating
stuff if you're not already a daily i
remember head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked for 20 off
ben created this show to give you the
confidence to counter every argument
your crazy leftist friend throws your
way he's ready to debunk nine more
arguments with you over the coming weeks
use code debunked debunked debunked
debunked for 20 off off your daily wire
membership today we'll be right back
with a lot more
750 000
that is the number of illegal aliens
that joe biden has released into the
united states since taking office
that is not the number of illegal aliens
who have come into the united states
since biden took office
that number is more like what
two and a half million or something or
more probably more than that at this
point
no
750 000 is the number of illegal aliens
that joe biden and his administration
caught that they then just released into
america
uh that is
that is according to a brief that was
dated april 14th it was filed in the
supreme court by stephen miller's
american first legal foundation
750 000 is larger than the population of
boston
750 000
is equal to the population of denver
750 000 is larger
than the population of detroit
every
what now 15 months
16 months joe biden
is dropping a new major american city
worth of foreign nationals
into this country
and he's doing it not necessarily
because they're going to vote for him in
the next election though some of them
might there's
this is how you know that the democrats
are banking on illegal aliens voting in
elections is when they tried to pass
their big uh
their big omnibus election bill they
they made it such that
uh
illegal alien people would be registered
to vote automatically
and they said illegal aliens will not be
registered to vote but
illegal aliens will have
immunity they'll have amnesty if they
are registered to vote so they won't
face any legal consequences but i
thought they weren't going to be
registered to vote in the first place
well no they're not but then so why do
you need to protect them when they are
well because because because so they're
counting on some illegal aliens voting
in
the upcoming elections but really what
they're banking on is the long game they
know that because our our view of
birthright citizenship today in 2022 in
america means that these illegal aliens
kids will be u.s citizens and they can
vote and we know just statistically
speaking that these kids and grandkids
are going to be overwhelmingly likely to
vote for democrats reagan said 40 40
years ago 50 years ago now almost that
illegal event illegals that hispanics or
republicans they just don't know it yet
we've seen movement of hispanics to the
republican camp but nowhere near
the kind of numbers that we would need
to justify the
illegal immigration
illegal immigration has only benefited
democrats it has only harmed republicans
we've been waiting for the new arrivals
to realize they're republicans it just
hasn't quite happened yet and so
democrats know if they can keep doing
this every year
little over a year
you drop a new boston a new detroit a
nuke denver in america full of illegals
overwhelmingly likely to vote for
democrats how long can you tolerate that
before the country is just swarming with
democrats
that's a huge number of people
and and frankly biden might not even
know about it joe biden was just asked a
question about the border
and he responded with an answer about
the cdc's mask ruling
i'm title 42
no what i'm considering is continuing to
hear from my
uh my uh first of all there's going to
be an appeal
by the justice department
because as a matter of principle we want
to be able to be in a position where if
in fact it is
strongly concluded by
the
scientists that we need title 42 that
we'd be able to do that but there has
been no decision on extending title 42.
so
joe biden clearly just doesn't know what
title 42 is and joe biden clearly just
doesn't know what the reporter was
asking him title 42 refers to a
provision of the law that regulated how
illegal aliens could cross the border
given the pandemic so it was a way to
use the the public health lockdowns in
the public health emergency to in some
way sort of possibly
curtail illegal immigration you saw that
at the end of the trump administration
and then
and then into the biden administration
so the question about title 42
is really about how come illegal aliens
are not subject to covet measures now
but american citizens still are
because you want american citizens to be
locked down but you don't want the
border to be locked down because illegal
aliens flooding over the border helps
you politically that's what the
question's about and joe biden had no
clue what this person was talking about
and so he thought that the question was
referring to the the
judge lifting the public transportation
mask mandate
it reminds you that in politics a lot of
it's ideological a lot of it's about
vision for the country but there is an
aspect of the job that just comes down
to basic competence and joe biden
doesn't have it he was never the
sharpest tool in the shed the dude was
always a doofus for his entire 50 years
in politics everyone made fun of him
barack obama is still making fun of the
guy he was the laughingstock when obama
came to the white house
obama just came back to visit at the
white house no one wanted to talk to joe
biden joe biden was just stumbling
around trying to get into conversations
obama's pushing him away because no one
has any respect for this guy he's not
wielding a ton of power himself he's a
joke okay and he's not competent and his
brain is made of pudding i hate to put
it in such harsh terms and so bluntly
but that's that's the way it is
and so this is another reason why why
america's enemies are advancing right
now is because you've got this this guy
at the helm of the ship of state who who
is not in control of himself who doesn't
really know even basic aspects of his
own policy he came back later on when
someone told him that he made this
mistake and he said i want to clarify
that
in comments at the conclusion of my
remarks this morning i was referring to
the cdc's mass mandate and there's no
department of justice action on title
42. yeah of course we we all knew that
we knew don't worry buddy go back to
watching matlock go back to your nice
comfy armchair with a nice warm glass of
milk we know we know that you're not
really the one calling the shots here we
know that the blob is just kind of
operating on its own and you are nothing
but a vague and
disappearing figurehead they are going
to try to lock down again though
regardless of what biden wants or
doesn't want or knows or doesn't know
the libs are going to try to lock down
again they're furious that this
trump appointed federal judge lifted the
mass mandate struck down the cdc's
stupid mass mandate they're furious
because the mandates and the lockdowns
and the whole covid regime
makes it a lot easier for them to hold
on to power
i told you this from day one
i hate to say i told you so i hate to
put on my nostradamus hat in my crystal
ball and tell you what's going to happen
but i said it from day one
even when there were many conservatives
who said the masks aren't political but
it's just about public health it was
never about public health it was always
just a political symbol and it was a
political symbol to justify upending all
the ordinary standards all the way of
life shutting down businesses completely
rewriting the rules for elections
i i knew even in recent months when when
they said okay we're going to go back to
normal now no you're not you haven't
gotten rid of the national emergency
authorization you haven't really taken
away fouchy's power in the cdc's power
they didn't want to lift the mask
mandate they're still trying to extend
it just another two weeks right where
have we heard that before just another
two weeks to slow the spread so it
wasn't real it was hurting them in the
polls so they tried to be a little
subtler about it but they want to bring
this thing back
they have to bring this thing back and
they are in certain liberal places la
just reinstated the mass mandate
at the airports and on the public
transportation how can they do that i
thought that the the judge just shut it
down well you're now seeing a political
battle between the cdc and a federal
judge and l.a county
and so
l.a county now is responding to the
judge and saying no actually you're
going to have to put your masks back on
again expect to see this if l.a county
gets away with it expect to see this
elsewhere around the country what was
the argument well according to
not the
supervisor of la county not the mayor of
los angeles not even the governor of
california according to the la county
public health director barbara farrer
she said public transportation hubs that
are indoors are places where there is a
a lot of mingling b they're often
crowded and c in some of those settings
it's really hard to have adequate
ventilation
so
they are the experts the cdc
they made a determination that at this
point having that requirement in place
is necessary for the public's health and
that resonates with us and so we're
going to reinstate it they're the
experts first of all
airplanes have never been a major source
of covet spread whatever you think about
kovid
the libs were always waiting for
airplanes to be the big source of spread
it never happened
totally never happened
never mind the hypocrisy that the libs
were encouraging blm riots without masks
by the way but they were shutting down
all of the conservative places you leave
open the pot dispensaries you close down
the churches never mind all of that
hypocrisy just focus on that word
experts they're the cdc they're the
experts are they
i doubt their expertise frankly even on
disease at this point because they've
held every wrong answer on kovit for the
past two years but furthermore they're
not the experts when it comes to setting
policy
they're at least not supposed to be
we're supposed to be the experts this is
self-government
or at least it's supposed to be the
masks and and the public transport rules
and the lockdowns that is a political
matter and in self-government in
republics political matters are supposed
to be decided by us
the people we are the experts
so what you're seeing here is not a
battle over the science which by the way
this
the science on the masks has been uh i
think in our favor from day one as
fouchy admitted before he switched his
view
the the question at hand is who governs
us who governs us
this was scalia's point in in the
obergefell decision and a completely
unrelated decision that redefined
marriage to include monogamous same-sex
unions in scalia's descent he said i'm
not even really interested primarily in
the question of what marriage is
my primary question today is who governs
us is it the cdc
is it a federal judge in this case i
guess better than nothing is it the la
public health officials who is it is it
us
what is this about
the libs are willing to go to any
lengths to upend our political order
there is a really bizarre and sad story
out of did you know it was earth day
last week it was earth day i totally
missed it i don't know that wasn't
marked off on my liturgical calendar but
i guess it was earth day
a man
burned himself to death a man committed
suicide by lighting himself on fire at
the supreme court
to protest
air pollution
to protest
what he thinks is global warming
this man win bruce it was a 50 year old
climate activist
and he was taken to a local hospital
after he set himself on fire and then he
died
of his of his injuries
he he's obviously was obviously a
mentally disturbed man who committed
suicide it's this is a sad story we
should all feel bad about but some of
his friends don't think that you should
feel bad about that there is one guy a
zen buddhist priest an environmental
scientist dr k kriti who said this guy
was my friend he meditated with our
sangha this act is not suicide this is a
deeply fearless act of compassion to
bring attention to the climate crisis so
first of all it was suicide when you
kill yourself that's suicide by
definition
this
buddhist dude or the climate guy who
killed himself they can try to justify
suicide they're not going to be
successful at that because suicide is
not justifiable but
regardless it is suicide you at a
certain point you do have to call a spay
to spay that's just
what to kill yourself is to commit
suicide
there's a further irony here which is
the guy committed suicide in order to
protest fossil fuels
how do you light himself on fire
i don't know there isn't a lot of
reporting on this
in the
most famous historical examples of
people setting themselves on fire to
protest things the vietnam war for
instance
people usually
pour gasoline on themselves
so it makes it even sadder because
probably the way this dude killed
himself was by burning up some
fossil fuels even if it were just the
plastic in his clothing
seems to be an incoherent action
to protest
fossil fuels by burning up some fossil
fuels and releasing it into the
environment and killing yourself along
the way
that is disordered stuff
again
totally outside of the political process
this guy wasn't protesting
global warming or whatever by picketing
outside of an oil company headquarters
he wasn't doing it by lobbying his
representatives in the government
he just killed him he committed an
illegal action
he committed violence against himself it
wasn't against libs of tick tock or some
conservative but it was against himself
he committed an act of violence because
he was so
dead set on upending the political
process for his disturbed
views
that's what they're doing aoc is
is leaking this as well she's
foreshadowing this as well this is not
about what's going on today this isn't
about gas prices this isn't about
immigration this isn't about the war in
ukraine this is all about
2022 and really 2024.
the libs are setting the stage to upend
once again our ordinary systems of
electoral politics to try to rig into
cheat and to keep the conservatives out
of it
aoc
is
speaking out on january 6th you know
that the libs have really tried to make
january 6th happen and it hasn't worked
just like the mean girls tried to make
the word fetch happen and that didn't
work well january 6th is not working
either and you you don't need to take my
word for you just look at the polls
january 6 is not resonating with voters
no one cares no one believes that the
horn hat guy was about to
shred the constitution and take over the
government no one believes that that
midwestern dad who cracked coors light
in the capital rotunda posed an
existential threat to the republic it
just no one buys it it's just complete
crap that the reports that came out from
that day were were just made up the idea
that the january 6 people killed cops it
didn't happen it was just it was just
fake news and even the washington post
and the new york times finally had to
admit that it was fake news they just
ran their corrections on page z 2000 of
the paper so no one no one saw them
among the times and the the washington
post's audience but nevertheless it was
made up it's not resonating with voters
and aoc is still trying to make it
happen
if we lose the house
this is no joke january 6 was a trial
run
and a lot of people don't seem to
understand that
it was a trial run
[Music]
and they're going to come back and they
win the house here's the thing the
technicality of what happened on january
6. the only reason it wasn't worse was
because democrats had the house and they
didn't have the votes in the house
if they take the if they take the house
then they have the votes to not
authorize and legitimize the
presidential election
whatever the results are
and so this is very serious
this is very serious january 6th was a
trial a trial run of what
of what they what happened on january
6th
a rowdy crowd
with potentially some
federal officials in involved in this
whole thing i don't know i would never i
don't want to deal in crazy conspiracy
theories but i i still want to know who
ray epps is i still want to i'm still
curious about that justice for january
6th rally where it looked like it was
basically a a field trip from quantico
of of guys all looking around looking
like the most
fed
you know
buzzed haircut looking dudes on planet
earth i am curious and i think a lot of
congressional republicans are curious
about
the fbi's role in january 6 i think
we're curious as to who planted the
bombs remember we were told that there
were bombs planted outside the dnc
headquarters well
what happened with that did we ever
catch the guy who planted the bombs that
seems like a pretty big deal shouldn't
we know a lot there are a lot of
questions
but we we do know
that the the feds just got caught
setting up and entrapping people to try
to and trying to create a plot to go
kidnap
democrat governor whitmer in michigan we
do know that we do know the feds do this
we do know there was some involvement
anyway anyway i'm just raising questions
but what was the trial run for
beyond all the noise it was that
some republicans didn't believe the 2020
election they thought there were
shenanigans and they wanted there to be
a a debate a recount paul gosar and ted
cruz proposed this idea of of an
electoral commission we saw this in the
1870s when there were similar questions
about the presidential election to go in
and investigate so we know that we have
faith in our elections i don't think
there's anything crazy about that
the democrats still haven't conceded the
2016 election the democrats still
haven't conceded the 2000 election so i
don't i don't think there's anything
wrong with raising questions and trying
to make sure our electoral processes are
sound what's the trial run
the trial run for what what what aoc is
trying to do
is
set the stage to
delegitimize republican political action
that's what they're that's what she's
trying to do she's trying to say these
guys they're a threat to democracy they
can't be allowed to run for office
marjorie greene madison co-author and
gym they can't you can't let donald
trump who this is really all about you
can't let them run for office oh gosh if
they run for office that'll be a threat
to the republic to save democracy we
have to destroy democracy to save the
constitution we need to shred the
constitution that's what they're going
to say we can't let these people get
their voice out in public
no no they need to be kicked off of
twitter they need to be removed from the
public square which is where you do
politics in in a republic yeah that no
in order to save free speech we have to
destroy free speech that's that's going
to be the argument it's just a way to
justify the further persecution of
conservatives now two years out from a
presidential election speaking of crazy
women i've got to get to this i meant to
get to it at the end of last week and we
didn't have time amber heard
amber hurd is some celebrity lady i
guess she was married to johnny depp who
is a much better known celebrity man
and
she accused him of doing all sorts of
terrible things to her but then it turns
out it looks like she did a lot of
terrible things to him and now they're
in court talking about this and during
this time in court they played a clip of
of this woman sounding like a complete
lunatic
i said to travis i said no i said to you
hey
tell travis what just happened are you
telling me to do it you told me to you
said go do that i said no tell him what
you're saying i lied and that you
punched me in the right
thing you figured it out
and you said no
i didn't what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
and
i'm sorry that i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched
don't tell me what it feels like to be
punched you know even a lot of fights
been around a long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not [ __ ] deck you i was
hitting you i don't know what the motion
of my actual hand was but you're fine i
did not hurt you i did not punch you i
was hitting you how are you how what am
i supposed to do do this
i'm not sitting here about it am i you
are that's the difference between me and
you you're a [ __ ] baby
because you started you are such a baby
girl the [ __ ]
johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
because out of there yes you did so you
did the right thing the big thing the
you know what you are admirable
okay so this woman is admitting to doing
all the stuff that she accused her
ex-husband of doing to her
she's obviously a complete lunatic i
don't have any real sympathy or anything
for her
except that
i can't really join the pity party
entirely for johnny depp because
the guy needs to get control of his
household okay the guy needs to lead
okay the
to quote tony soprano whatever happened
to strong men whatever happened to the
quiet silent type whatever happened to
gary cooper
okay what you're what you're seeing
happen here
at the level of this family such as it
is and the family is the building block
of society so it's the fundamental
political unit you're seeing it
throughout the entire society is just
complete disorder
complete disorder
i i don't know what spark came between
these two that led them to get married
in the first place but something tells
me it might not have been totally
the most virtuous of reasons and there
was total disorder here he wasn't
leading his family she's a complete
lunatic and was was allowed to just do
whatever she wanted it it's
there was a line in the crown
speaking of hollywood the show about the
queen and the royal family which is that
it's in the little things that the rot
begins it's in the little things the
little things you just let people get
away with the little the little
injustices that you just let go
unanswered and then that spreads and
that spreads like a cancer throughout
society and that there is no question
when you introduce the insane amount of
disorder
into the family that we have in the last
50 years into the political community
for instance by erasing our national
borders that we have in the last 50
years when you the kind of disorder
where you give a handful of oligarchs
the control over all of speech you know
when you introduce this kind of radical
social disorder your political system is
going to go
insane the answer to that is not some
long soliloquy about freedom in the
abstract or equality in the abstract or
rights in the abstract the answer is get
a hold of your political community
bring some stability and order back to
the family bring some stability and
order back to the borders but we need
order in the country before we can talk
about any of these sorts of things
otherwise the political system is going
to go up in flames i'm michael knowles
it's the michael nola show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show